welcome back to this guest who's only
been in some of the most popular and
iconic films of our time and Yellowstone
which was the most-watched new cable
series last year on paramount Network is
back for season two in the Dutton family
is back in the patriarch of that family
the actor two-time Academy Award winner
and Golden Globe winner Kevin Costner
good to see you sir nice to see you
buddy
so we just saw you moments ago role in a
couple putts here on our Callaway corner
and you were saying I overheard you that
it's been a while since you you got out
there on the golf course yeah I don't
get out much that movie that that tin
cup movie kind of gave people the
impression that was something I did all
the time and then playing at Pebble
Beach that reinforced it so but I don't
and I think sometimes that when I play
it's in front of millions of people it's
a yeah I know guys that can't tee off
with the first tee because some guy
eating pancakes it at Bellaire goes and
they Shh but every time I play if it
feels like it's in front of a billion
people right well did you who what what
sort of preparation did you do for that
movie I mean how Mary and Pete Costas
Gary McCord and Pete Costas did you try
to help me as much as I could but as we
all know too much information about golf
it's just I could only absorb a few
things right the one thing that I took
away in that thing is I wouldn't have a
beautiful swing there it was he was a
little West Texas golfer used to plan on
mewni courses in the wind so everything
was like a knockdown shot so I I kind of
played the movie that way a lot I mean
he made it up kind of like Trevino if
you would but those guys were always
great and you know I had you know the
great experiences for the fact I
actually played a Palm Spring thing
because they wanted to try to introduce
me to golf as much as I could I said
come down to the Palm Spring thing and I
go okay and I swear to God and I watched
it's not like I'm a rube but you don't
really get it quite away you know it
when you're doing it with them and
actually you know on the second hole I
feel like I picked up everybody's marks
I picked up my money and I I thought we
were out of the hole and there was a
moment in time were actually the marshal
there froze everybody froze it was like
on a second hole I picked up
Ares thing or whatever and I realized
something that happened I remember I my
quick saw the Marshall who saw what
happened he was sitting right on his
little three stool thing yes and I said
I picked this up and putting it right
back we're just gonna keep going okay
and I did I he looked at me and I don't
know my voice carried yes
and I said I'm putting it right back
down here let's not make a big deal
about this I was just picking up the
stuff it was like and so the he's
playing late on he played on play on he
played on I had another terrible
experience I might as well just tell
this I'll go for Kim that same that exam
experience was also with pros it was
that pro-am out there and I don't know
why I'm telling you this but I'm I'm out
there and I'm now gonna be between Peter
Jacobsen and somebody else and I'm like
anything I don't want to necessarily go
hit in front of them right away
you know seventh grade you don't take
your first shower and forehead
everybody's like what am I gonna do here
I don't want to hit I don't want to and
I'm not sure how to go about this and so
I'm kind of waiting from my spot and my
caddie was a kid I was sponsoring at USC
he comes over and he goes what's he goes
what's in your bag
I said what because your bag and I said
what are you talking about cuz I'm
writing he goes I had two guns in there
I had two guns I was what was it what it
was I hadn't been in my bag for about
seven months after that movie when I was
out there and in Arizona because I
wasn't that great at golf I loved like
hunting quail and rabbit so I play about
six holes in the evening when the light
was perfect right and then I had a
little 22 and and and and and at two
little 22 is I pissed on the thing and
so I would like you know get some quail
or some rabbit and then I and that's
what I did and I didn't and I didn't and
I was still in the back because it had
the head covers on it so he goes what do
I do and I said he goes there's ammo to
like well there should be but he goes I
go with a I said just take it back to
the car I I haven't I don't want to hit
in front of these guys anywhere I could
use the stall he was white face because
he was gonna be a pro well the a low is
usually a Callaway heavy yeah and the
there's no 22
the cover was over the thing I take my
young son out and we would start playing
up for when the Sun got low and sure we
would hot your caddy just just we can
remain calm yeah you gotta go because
it's heavy it was heavy
that's right cuz normally when the bag
is heavy they're looking in there to see
what they could take out if they're
gonna be a he knew right away something
was wrong so he couldn't figure out he
counted the clothes but he didn't take
the head cover off he says it still
ready they pulled it off and then
there's the 22 Kevin Costner here on the
Rich Eisen show and it's interesting
that US Open is at Pebble Beach this
week right now right and so here we go
what was it like playing a petal that
was beautiful for me that's the most
beautiful of course I've ever been on I
just you know you you get out there and
there's these all these people and when
you're on the course you get angles and
no one else get it yes and it is the
most dynamic beautiful course for me at
least Kevin Costner here on the Rich
Eisen show so what do you do when you're
not acting and you do you bike do you
hike I mean huge obviously you're not
out there in the Gulf
I love taking my family outdoors I mean
I'm headed to British Columbia with them
you know next week and we'll you know
we'll be salmon fishing the eight nine
and ten and we've already got the bets
in place and stuff like that you know
like what do you mean just you know
biggest fish anything to connect keeping
mentor said I'm really dying to see how
my young daughter you know does out
there because it's a fishing trip that's
what it is and and you know I I don't
want to leave her out of this
experience so she can say next year if
she wants to do it or not but I want her
to have it
mm-hmm so you know I'm uncertain how
she's gonna deal with it because it's
you go to a lodge and that's what you do
and it takes some patience obviously but
any kid will do that but what if she
does catch the first fish I mean like
what I already explained to her the
money dealing so well that's a great
Father's Day situation obviously and
with it Father's Day this weekend again
Yellowstone is on the paramount network
and we will hit that in a second of the
TV show that just lit up ratings and
screens last year and season two is
coming up the thought that to me and
we've had this conversation before
to me what makes a good sports movie is
you could have all obviously the great
sports moments or the actor or actress
you know the relationship between man
and woman to me it's the father-son
relationship any good sport any great
sports movie has a father-son
relationship
yeah and I have any time I see field of
dreams any time playing wherever I am I
I cry
I mean I've missed up I know it's coming
I know the moment the father-son moment
them and the movies coming but I just oh
yeah I know that thing that goes
unspoken between father and son and and
it's not just men that enjoy that movie
but that unfit that thing when we go too
long without saying what we really mean
to each other you know that movie it
moves people not only to tears but it
moves them to that shoulder crying that
kind of draw where you can't you can't
quite get your breath because you've
missed the moment and and that that
movie did it that was our big car crash
that was our big fight that was our big
cavalry charge it was you want to have a
catch and when you know and so you know
you know like yeah you know a lot of
people they people they visit revisit
that moment but you know the other thing
that struck me was not only that
particular one with that but the speech
that James Earl Jones does always struck
me in the sense that not to say that
James Earl Jones isn't an athlete but
it's it's it's hard to imagine
Manoel or maize or Williams ever
articulating the sport the way he was
able to so you have a non athlete
articulate the sport that we all love
and play till the streetlights come on
season this season that's that's what's
so remarkable about that movie that like
a chalkboard at a races and everything
that was good
could still be again and it took a
non-athlete
it took a literary guy to actually
explain to athletes what it is they just
know intuitively but would have a hard
time I think explaining well and it's
still true right I mean that that that
speech never ever gets old Wow right
exactly
what was it like shooting that scene
though with rakin Silla and his father I
mean did how many how long did that do
that at these could you notice that we
did that at Magic Hour you also notice
that when that shot pulled back and you
saw those cars you know now but that
would have been CG but that was
technically that was all extras that we
called in the radio come be in our movie
and they created that big traffic jam
hold on a second so that traffic jam
that's a real that's a real shot and
that people from Iowa came and so so
many people feel like they're a part of
that movie so those thousands and
thousands of cars that were in that
giant traffic jam that went out on those
two lanes that was real when it went out
over the radio they didn't know what
they were doing they supported the movie
now looking back they know they were a
part of it that's amazing yeah we would
have been able to get simple now with
the way movies work but that was how we
gonna get them all here we just said
call them tell them they want to be in a
movie they'll come to of course if you
if you call them they will come that's
the lot of children say they were born
on that night it's really fun you need
to talk to people and they go it was an
amazing experience but in terms of
playing it in terms of as you said the
the quiet moment before the the the
speaking that was left unsaid yeah how
did you work that Kevin well I know what
it did what I did was I went back to
when I first read it and so I become the
audience when I read it and I when I
read it I want I couldn't believe that
had orchestrated itself to that thing
and I had that feeling on the couch and
so I knew if I played that straight but
I didn't wink at anybody mm-hmm that
these players did come you know that's
my corner and I knew that that was
possible and that's what I do when I
look at movies I I put us audience on my
shoulder it's not like I you know I
don't understand you know people that
make a movie they don't understand or
they're surprised that it was good I try
to make a movie when I start when I can
see why it would work I can also tell
sometimes during the process of when
we're slipping away from what was good
and for as gentle a movie as Field of
Dreams really is
you what you really have to understand
is the fine line that we had to play in
order to people not reject us as a movie
like come on in the real and the real
value of this movie I get so much credit
for this movie and really it's it's with
Phil Robinson who wrote it and directed
it kind of a non-athlete himself but an
artist and you know Phil Robinson is the
architect of that movie you know I tell
a story you know and I don't tell it
what often but you know that they kept
coming after me I wasn't gonna be able
to do that movie I was gonna do revenge
and I got into a finally that revenge
kept getting pushed kept getting pushed
and finally I had to put my foot down
and say look if you don't get this movie
together I'm gonna go to do this movie
in the corn that's what I'm gonna do and
the guy said I'll sue you and I go I
figured that was the first thing coming
out of your mouth and and we went at it
and I said I heard you were smart
heard you were smart guy mm-hmm I said
how come you can't figure this out I
said we'll go to court or you figure it
out and he did he figured it out he goes
the day you in that corn movie four days
later you come to me on my set that's
when I stay at this and you said to
ranch I'll tell you that story someday
but I asked the director why did you
hold out for me so long why and he said
well and this is one of the greatest
actors were ever seen he goes they
wanted me to do it Robin Williams and I
said I said riot but Robin Williams is
perfect he said yeah but when I think of
Robin I think he does hear voices in the
corn and I don't want that people don't
believe you're here voices and that was
a really interesting that was it that's
a director that makes a save that's a
Mariano Rivera you know it sure it's a
save he saved his movie because of his
belief in an idea and you know not the
quality of actor because Robin Williams
will never of course this is this is a
guy so special but I but I was curious I
said he's actually a bigger star than me
you know a you know whatever and he goes
I need somebody that you don't think
cares voices and that would be you I've
never heard Robin Williams was
considered for that role
that's unbelievable and then you did it
and obviously we're we're talking about
it today yeah yeah yeah it had gold dust
on it when I read it because I did that
little intake of breath do you want to
have a catch and of course I I wept
myself Kevin Costner here on the Rich
Eisen show we see so many movies today
or sequels you once told Roger Ebert
you'd never do a sequel do you remember
that conversant know that I said I've
never I never run into the sequel that I
would do yet you know to you know boy
you never want to get caught in the
never game but the truth was I
I love Bull Durham but I didn't need to
do a Bull Durham - and I love tin cup
and my bodyguard and I love those things
so I wasn't inclined to do them because
usually sequels are commissioned after
the first week in a box office right
they're not commissioned because
somebody's thought what the story is
gonna be their commission because they
know these movies are gonna work and I'm
I'm pretty anal in how I think about
things I like well I never
I need to see that the second Field of
Dreams is as good as the first one
because that movie means something to me
and they don't like to work it that way
they want to just put it in the can and
go so I wasn't inclined to do them
because I very rarely saw somebody I
will do a sequel I'm thinking of
directing one but I know how it works I
don't it doesn't work because it made
money it works from a literary
standpoint and you let me in on which
one you think it's a Western that I want
to do yeah it's a Western I want to do
and it covers thirty years and I I'm
gonna act in it and direct it and and
it's one of those things it just it it's
kind of like a field of dreams for me
not the same type of movie because it's
rough and tough but I have a lot of
moments when I read it where I just go I
just find that so it's something you've
been in before the sequel that's or you
know I'm gonna I'm gonna I want to I'm
gonna go make it and and it will it'll
be one two three oh you're gonna make
something that has so something original
with sequels that's right that's not
just asking a sequel of something that
you thought
gonna make a sequel of mr. Brooks
because that story kept going huh
but but but I haven't but you know been
inclined so I'm if I said that to Roger
I'll take that back I said ah but what
I'm you know I've never been able to
find one that I thought was better than
the next
so let me flip it for before we move to
Yellowstone here Kevin Costner which
story would you be interested in the
prequel of the character that you've
played so in advance you're you could do
a story or wondering about the story of
a character that you've portrayed
probably just circle this again the this
Western I'm telling you about the the
original script was written 20 years ago
I haven't made it and started thinking
about what would be like because a lot
of times on westerns you don't know who
the character is coming off the
landscape right you don't know about the
town all you know really is the town's
having trouble this guy coming in
actually probably has the tools to solve
this but what we believe is he's trying
to leave his life behind
that's the architecture of the
gunfighter leaving his life behind but
he comes into a town that's in need of
just that thing and so if it's gonna be
great this story is gonna have to be
great because that's the cliche that's
the formula you want to give up this
town needs you and so that film I'm
talking about 20 years ago had those
elements but the longer I began to think
about it I thought what if the guy
coming in we know everything about what
if the town he's coming into you know
exactly how it came to be and that's
what's resulted in this this ongoing
movie that I want to do now let's talk
Yellowstone Kevin Costner here on the
Rich Eisen show a tremendous first
season an average of 5.1 million total
viewers per episode that's tops for a
new show on cable what do you think
worked for Yellowstone so well last year
that you are back for season 2 debuting
next Wednesday I guess people could have
found the channel it might have doubled
it was the first show on Parramatta and
my dad kept saying people don't know how
to find this Kevin and I get those phone
calls a lot it was like I like it and I
don't like how you're behaving either
your mother is not very happy with the
language most of people here in assisted
living
don't don't want to watch it you know I
get those I get those calls you know and
so I have to deal with I said you're
right that it's look colorful isn't it
yes it is and so you know I got to pass
the mother test all the time sure still
well it's good but it's you know it's
it's it's a it's a it's a world I only
thought I was gonna do one season there
was a couple reasons why elected to play
it out for them but it's been it's been
nice to you know there's a lot of movies
that deal with the lawyer in the
hospital and the inner streets and
sometimes when you put stories and
they're set against the way the country
still exists you can still go out there
and see it I'm working in a valley that
the exact same valley the exact same
river that Lewis and Clark went down
there's something beautiful and special
and you see it every day and I think
when people see the imagery of horses
set against these mountains these
valleys that are the same thing as they
were thousands and thousands of years
ago not since 1873 or not since 1973 but
thousands and thousands of years ago it
takes me back I think people are
enjoying that the visual just as much
and then some of the politics and
intrigue I mean this isn't like
something set in 1873 this is now and
they'll say you're right you're really
right about that because those problems
were arbitrated differently back then
there were no agents there were no
publicity
there was no lowering it with the people
arbitrated and that and that fabric is
keeps itself still established in the
Western those western states to be
honest there's still that mentality
although people know they can't put
hands on each other they're not supposed
to but that mentality is really alive
but when we're Yellowstone picks up the
family is incredibly dysfunctional it's
just as dysfunctional as can be but he's
dealing with those external pressures
that you're talking Native American
issues urbanization environmental
protection everything that this one guy
who's really a CEO of this land he's the
one guy that's maybe going to lose it
out of all because these pressures are
not
thing he can deal with in the
old-fashioned wine it's a 10 Eastern and
Pacific on paramount Network and if you
need help finding it just ask Kevin's
dad he knows exactly how to find that
easy got to clean up that language fella
clean it up mother's watching and
everybody here at the place is watching
next Wednesday at 10:00 Eastern in
Pacific before I let you go
you've told some great stories here on
the show you've told one about a hackman
and no way out you told one about Burt
Lancaster obviously from Field of Dreams
and from The Untouchables Sean Connery
do you have a De Niro one a good Robert
De Niro story from The Untouchables
which by the way is one of those remote
drop movies for me doesn't matter where
I write what I'm doing where I'm picking
it up if it's just five minutes in or
with five minutes to go I am dropping
the remote at all I had I had a hard
time with with with De Niro and not
because of him but because of my
character and and I remember I didn't
exact or I didn't exactly know you know
how to deal with it but I was I was a
straight and narrow guy on that batter
thing and so my dialogue was really
precise and we got into this big scene
where he kept going what what and what
cause may have to repeat but it's like I
couldn't get off the page with the with
the kind of street language he could get
and and and and and and and Connor it
was just listen to mr. Ness you know
when to get in it and he goes don't try
to compete don't try to compete mr. Ness
and he was mr. Ness call me mr. Nash mr.
Nash and but he was helpful to me
because because De Palma it was right
you know he's a gangster he's going and
I I had to deal with him with the
language that Mamet had and I really
learned a lot I've also he's also every
time I've seen him he's also treated me
really great in that that's nice and
then his scene with the baseball bat
it's a very different it's not a sports
movie obviously but in terms of
soliloquies involving sports he really
handled that he really handled that
scene great because it's it's a I
remember reading you're not thinking
that's tough
language to deal with it he commanded it
he made that circle De Palma did his
little circle thing oh yeah but she
loves and so you know that was a that
was a that was a big moment for me that
whole that whole thing I mean listen I
had one kind of embarrassing moment
there I was I was actually talking with
Sean and they had yellow tape keeping
people way back and I was talking to him
and this one very beautiful woman kept
saying mmm and it was like bit but it
was and I was thinking I I'm talking to
him I got like what and then was like
and and after you know a minute or so I
finally kind of made why I went and I
said I said yeah she goes could you get
me mr. Connery's autograph and I thought
[Laughter]
that that's how big Sean was Sean was
the biggest with the biggest star
he's bond I mean as far as I'm concerned
he's that that's where it all started or
Nash mr. na that's so funny he would
call you that off yes yeah fantastic and
it's true with the with the DeNiro
speech I mean baseball when a man stands
alone at the plate it's time for
individual achievement but when you're
on the field you know part of a team
team you know teamwork teamwork you know
there's a story that's people's worth
knowing about Sean you'd want to know
whether the cameras rolling or not you
know there was a moment time he was
really upset man he was upset with the
producer he was upset that they had kept
him too long and for Sean money was very
very important not that it isn't for
everybody but he was gonna lose money
because the schedule was running and he
had to be out of the country in a
certain amount of days in his mind
he'd been promised okay got to keep that
in mind his mind hit but he'd been
promised and that started slipping away
and I'm telling you what he started to
boil and and it was a really interesting
moment I happen to be walking through
the hallway and he's he's in the bar and
he goes mr. Nash I heard it all the way
out that he goes come here I want to
talk to you and I go in to talk to him
and I'm thinking what does he really
want to talk to man he's got a yellow
legal pad and he's got a line down the
minute and he goes he tells me that he's
been promised things and he goes you've
been on the set every day and he and he
had this whole list of thing
that were wrong that didn't happen like
did that happen did that happen did that
happen I was like not nodding yes yes
yes yes and over here the one thing and
what it was and then he then went and
just towards somebody up but for him it
was important that that he had he's
clear about what he thought the truth
was sure and as I kept saying yeah
you're right there I'm thinking I'm
killing this guy he's gonna go talk I'm
literally killing this guy but Sean's
desire to be fair was what I've found
interesting and who he was I love having
you on Kevin thanks for coming on thanks
for making this part of anything you'd
ever do so I really appreciate you you
bet Yellowstone on the Paramount Network
premiering next Wednesday season to
10:00 p.m. Eastern and Pacific right
here on the Rich Eisen show for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel - 39 on DirecTV for free on BR
Live or download the Rich Eisen show app